what I teach now it's easier to make a
million than it is to work on minimum
wage and a person on minimum wage can
make the million and if you stay
contributing because I believe that
you're alive at the level of your
curiosity you're alive at the level of
your imagination so the bigger your
imagination the better reality you have
all you need is the idea and then you
borrow all the resources so one idea
plus the right contact equals unlimited
result the reason you get rich is so you
can afford to do the stuff that nobody
else can afford to do you don't get rich
at at a low level at an ego level you
know you get rich for s you got to have
a big dream you got to have a great team
and then the third principle I teach is
you got to have multiple streams you got
to have a dream Martin Luther King said
I have a dream number two is you got to
have a team King had a team everybody
that succeeds has a team now Mark Victor
Hansen is best known for what time
magazine called the publishing
phenomenon of the decade he's the
founder of the Chicken Soup for the Soul
book series which has sold over 500
million copies worldwide in this
exclusive interview with Chris Weidner
you'll hear Mark's best advice on
expanding your vision Beyond
conventional limits maintaining belief
in your product despite rejection and
implementing proven marketing strategies
for unparallel success and we've got
Chris's permission to put it up on our
YouTube channel enjoy welcome Mark
thanks for having me yeah good to have
you here I'm elated yeah so let's let's
Dive Right into um into your book
Chicken Soup for the Soul 110 million
copies right at at at uh previous uh
count is is 110 million probably going
to be a little bit more than that if you
have anything to do about it right yep
oh yeah we're our goal is because I
teach people to think bigger than they
ever thought they could think Chris so
our goal is to sell a billion books by
2020 ad that's our perfect 2020 vision
and uh all my critics which I have a
fair amount of say that can't be done I
say well look I'm 10% of gold and and
you know all those Publishers at the
front end said you couldn't do it and
then our agent fired us and then you
know so we've gone through a lot of
fiery Hoops to get here and and we got
some new cool stuff happening and and
there's a World Market with 7 billion
people and you know we've taken Market
places that no one else has ever tried
to touch like chicken soup of the
expectant mother Soul where you know
there's 90 million newborns a year and
we just want that Niche and we want it
through every OBGYN in the world yeah
now um one of the things that I find
that people think when they look at a
person like yourself highly successful
famous wealthy and they'd look and oh
man if I could just well you're
wealthier than I am Mark and I'm
probably more than a lot of people I
would imagine imagine you got a little
nickel or two off that 110 million books
but I mean but people will look at that
and they'll say oh they must have just
skated to it they must have life must
have been good you know whatever but
there's a story behind the the Chicken
Soup for the Soul and how long it took
you and how hard it was to get to get it
out the door right yeah Jack and I were
friends for like 25 years he came to one
of my seminars a long long time ago down
we were both on a big program for uh the
mandala which is 6,000 people at a
health conference and uh he came I was
doing a seminar called triple your
income double your time off and Jack was
sitting in front row and took a lot of
notes and here's a guy smarter than heck
out of Harvard and and he said can I
take you to lunch I said sure and and we
befriended each other and then years
later on at a talk he's doing up in uh
Hollywood at you know you get up at 4:00
for the six o'clock breakfast meeting we
were on the board of this company called
in Inside Edge and
um I said what's happening he said I
want to write this little book you know
because we I taught them how to do the
dramatic heart-touching story that you
know gets people to cry and then they
want to buy our books and and like I
talked to 10,000 Marines and they said
we don't cry but you made our eyeball
sweaty and uh but you have that story in
a book so I could do my family and so he
said why don't we do a book and and so
we decided to do it we spent three years
doing it our wives said you know you
guys have lived this because we were
doing 247 Mach 3 with our hair on fire
and um then we went to New York and and
33 Publishers said Hit the Road Jack and
I said if you don't like him it's okay
but I'm the nice guy here I'm teasing
he's a great guy and then our agent
fired us and we got that hanging an and
that's cost him probably 7 or 8 million
so far and in our um a little publisher
we went to the Book Expo 134 more people
turned us done a little publisher health
communication how many 134 more okay so
before you finish the story I got to ask
you 33 in New York 104 more this is
really a lesson for Life what kept you
going look we knew the book got standing
ovations we handed out little coupons
that said when when book comes out these
stories are going to be in it you know
will you take one now you can't take a
credit card cuz that's called a mail
fraud you know because if I take the if
if you give me your check and or credit
card or cash and I don't deliver in 6
weeks I that's mail fraud in America so
we couldn't take any money but we had
20,000 slips that said these people want
to buy this book nobody in New York
wanted it 20,000 and you know when I 12
years ago when I started this thing with
Jack that you do cartwheels for 20,000
because the average book sells about 5,
165,000 new books a year um you know
nowadays um there's some major
Publishers like Hay House at don't want
to touch anyone that sells less than
50,000 maybe later on we can talk about
how to do that but I don't want to do a
book personally now cuz we've gotten
chicken soup because because I teach a
whole seminar called uh me book Mega
book marketing um magic and and what
happens is I teach that you know chicken
soup we don't want to touch a market
that's less than three and a half
million we won't do a a book for medical
doctors because there's only uh 570,000
docks and you know only 10% of them Buy
sell 50,000 books would be great for
somebody else but nothing for us whereas
we do a Chicken Soup for the golfer Soul
we partner with Golf Digest you know the
first month they send it are you a
golfer by the way yeah yeah not much of
one but I golf but if you get Golf
Digest the order didn't your wife's
first name is Lisa so we did direct
marketing to Lisa and said Dear Lisa
you've gotten everything you got the
stupid pants he's already got the spike
shoes he's got the clubs but he doesn't
have this book and so he sold three and
a half million the first month when we
came out in November two years ago and
it just we we want to do I teach Grow
Rich in your Niche I want to take over
markets that nobody's messing with when
we started chicken soup You Know Jack
and I worked out a system and system is
something of acronymed and own the
trademark on save yourself time energy
and money and you know it's got to do in
in chicken soup it's got to do seven
things it's got to cause you to have
Goosebumps chili bumps or God bumps it's
got to you a lump in the throat it's got
to cause you have a change in perception
it's got to cause you a weaken the knees
like a change in perception we got a
letter from a prisoner said dear Mark
and Jack I've been in The Slammer 5
years contemplating the ideal crime
killing the guy who put me here then my
sister sent me your book I read it again
and again when I get out of here in five
more years I no longer want to kill a
guy that put me here well that is a
major change in perception I Define a
miracle as a change in perception so you
know what we do with chicken soup is
that we want instantaneous behavioral
change in other words we want you to
read it get it own it viscerally and
then go out and act on on that idea sort
of like what you did in your book 12
pillars where you know this guy comes
and and meets um Charlie and and every
day talk well it comes 12 times or 11
times I guess and you know learns it and
then goes out and does the exact action
for the next couple weeks yeah so you
knew in your heart people like this book
and that's what kept you going and
you're saying we've just got to find the
right publisher and because it seems to
me like so many people quit especially
if 137 people tell them never going to
happen yeah buzz off it's not going to
work well not only that we you know
bookstores didn't like us necessarily
any more than anybody else because
you're just another you know books come
in so fast and move on books now have a
one- month shelf if they don't blow and
go in a month they're done for like
Harry Potter I got to say that well I've
never met her you know RK Rawlings I
mean she sells more books and anybody
she's now world's bestselling fiction
author I'm world's bestselling
non-fiction author but our and I look
I've got her on my list of people to
meet but I mean she is the most
strategic brilliant lady I mean she had
people line up in front of all the
biggest bookstores and brought the media
out brought the camera because nothing
happens until the cameras are rolling in
America so you know she's been more
strategic and more uh intelligent it's a
lot of levels than I have and I'm I'm
and my partners and I'm very very
thankful for that and and you know so
I'm at a bookstore I'm at the world's
biggest bookstore in Canada it's at the
West Edmonton Mall it's like our Mall of
America same guys own both those and
there's nobody there so I went and got
balloons popped them started getting
people attention say did you read page
25 did you read page 65 it's a one
minute story that they go oh man that's
really touching I you know like it's the
same thing when we went to Vin deona to
do our TV show the guy who does
America's funest Home Videos does our TV
and
and for two hours he said look reality
TV is in Mark and Jack you guys are too
late and uh so his partner uh Lloyd win
trob said hey you know last night my
wife's a school teacher and uh books are
fun which is one of our big Distributors
you know came in with this book and she
read me a story and he told it perfect
he said little old man is on a bus on a
country road and he's carrying two dozen
red roses and a girl across the aisle as
drop dead gorgeous pluk rudness just
emanates out of every pore of her being
and she's you know GL dancing at the
flowers and the old man's ready to
shuffle foot off the bus walks up to her
laser flowers on her lap said I was
going to give them to my
wife but I think she'd like you to have
them she starts crying the old man
Shuffle foots off the bus as the bus
takes off she watches as he walks into
the
cemetery V Deon says we could do this as
a TV show and we got everybody we had
Rod stiger while he was alive we got
Charlie Sheen We Got You Know Jack Lemon
and and it's all because of the quality
of the story because a good actor knows
he or she is as only good as the writing
and Jack and I have you know we read a
thousand stories to find one that fits a
little curb called chicken soup so
here's the road and here's the curb you
know we got to you know people say well
you didn't use my story I said well it
didn't fit our model I mean even you
know our partner here who had dinner
last night Kyle Wilson I mean it's taken
him a long time to finish chicken soup
with the entrepreneurial Soul because
the story could be a great
entrepreneurial story but it it's not a
great entrepreneurial chicken soup story
an entrepreneur some of you Tak
something from a low value and makes it
a high value which is the most important
thing in the world as far as I'm
concerned we need more entrepreneurship
not less America right now is in such
deep Financial dire after such great
tragedies of of Katrina wil Marita and
you know 26 major disasters in last year
and more coming and fires and all kinds
of stuff is it so we spent $375 billion
do in hot checks I'm not saying it was
wrong but the only way to pay for that
is somebody becomes massively productive
and I'm so glad that we get to do a show
like this that says hey look as good as
you are you can be better as good as you
are you're you're over and doubt with 18
billion brain cells let's make a
decision put it in subconscious that
you're going to make massive amounts of
money serve others greatly create a a
lasting Legacy and and come from
abundance so um and and that's primarily
the way that you're getting all of this
information out to people is through
Chicken Soup for the Soul but now you're
doing it also through some book seminars
and tell us about the play that you're
doing now okay the truth is my purpose
statement is that uh I want to make I
want to make total Humanity a total
economic and physical success and and to
do that I'll use media which include
books and ebooks and tapes and videos
and TV and movies and films and uh and
documentaries because documentaries in
the last couple years you know last year
we had four documentaries that all blew
through 100 million who would think that
you'd have you know little documentaries
that are invisible like um McDonald's
doesn't like this but super siiz me
which sort of Beats them the one that
cuz you got all the kids at home I hope
you've watched spell Bond did you watch
spell Bond no I haven't seen that yet
spell bond is about the 10 million kids
that get in the spelling be every year
and then number one and right down here
in Texas we have a a totally illiterate
Hispanic family that has a girl go to a
swap meet and buy a $5 one of the big
fat uh dictionaries memorize every word
in the dictionary and she beats out
everybody she beats they they follow 10
people and they show all these people
that beat the crap out of their kids to
learn this stuff and she her parents are
illiterate she's on a farm that's
illiterate she's the borderline between
Mexico and and Texas and and she ends up
winning it and it just you cry all the
way through because you go there's no
way this chick can win and I don't mean
to blow it for anyone watching but so
you got documentaries like that and
we're just finishing our own documentary
right now and uh so and a play we're
doing with um our dear friend Paul
Williams now Paul Williams is one of the
three greatest lyricists of all times he
wrote most of Barbara strian songs of
Carpenter songs and he had a drug issue
which he talks about so I'm not talking
behind a friend's back then he came back
and he's just finished play that uh is
on both Broadway and starting right now
in in New York and and becoming number
one after producers in Las Vegas uh you
know called happy days which he did with
Gary Marshall and he did all the music
and just you know if you watch Happy
Days with the fonds in the old days now
you're going to go see this play and
it's going to you know it's going to be
Nostalgia for those of us looking back
and we're just finishing the chicken
soup play and it we think it'll be the
biggest play in the world because I'm I
teach in marketing Grow Rich in a niche
pick a niche that nobody's marketing so
I'm going into all towns under 100,000
like you know Largo and Moose Jaw and
and you know atas town you don't think
about or Boise Idaho that have you know
there's no media like it's no bleed over
media from Denver or no bleed over media
from La so you can do the media
inexpensively you can take and we'll
just you talking about a seminar that
you did in Boise and there was Zig
Ziggler who I guess you've interviewed
already and and you know zigg is the
senior superstar in our business he's
already flatlined and come back so he
come back from the dead you come back
from the dead J you're great man um
anyhow and and Zig is great and and what
happened Zig and I went in there and
there's a roughly 100,000 I think 96,000
exactly we had 10,000 people you know
show up just for the two of us and I
went whoa this is like way cool and so I
said you know if if you go into a big
city like La there's so much competition
because you got 18 million people or New
York 18 million but if you go into a
little city with 100,000 there nothing
happening so they go look this is the
event we'll go to that or you know yeah
going into dtas or something so and and
so I can very quickly pick that up off
and what what is astounding to me at at
you know cuz I've been doing this
business for over 30 years is it like
last week I got two telephone calls in
one day one from the Osman Donnie and
Marie they want to do something with me
and then I just hung up that phone I go
and and a week earlier it was down here
Willie Nelson and he had me uh you know
come down and help out with Farm Aid and
teach the farmers how to raise money and
it because it was after all those
terrible disasters he owns a place
called Carl's Corners that he's making
the next Branson and he's got Reba and
all of them and when I got down there I
was helping out was glad to help out cuz
I I believe that you're only as good as
a charity that you do in the
contribution you make and I wrote a
whole book called The Miracle of tithe
in which businessmen say what's a
miracle a tithing I said you haven't
been tided enough
lately anyhow but I got down with with
Willie and and Willie I don't know if
you've been to Carl's Corners here
because you don't really live in Texas
but um there a play at Carl's Corners he
has willly biodiesel and he spent all of
his fortune at 82 years old to figure
out how to crack legumes and take the
energy out of soy beans and mustard
seeds and peanuts like George Washington
Carver and I was running these giant
18-wheeler trucks saving the trucker
$30,000 minimum a year giving them
better fuel that burns smell it smells
like I hate diesel smell almost as much
I hate Airline kerosene smell but uh you
know and you shouldn't hate anything I
suppose but just it's noxious to a human
being but the now you got 18 wheeel
trucks taking off and it smells like
french fries Chris you just you
go you know you want to go eat the truck
or something and and what happens is
instead of being noxious to the
environment it's proactive to the
environment so what Willie has done is
he's hired all 50,000 Farmers that lost
$2 billion like if two cars hit at 160 m
hour everybody dies right the wind hits
at 160 mph the cows are gone the Sheep
are gone the crops are gone the houses
are gone and so Willie said hey wait a
second I'll hire all you guys and if we
really grow this uh we'll we'll reverse
the greenhouse effect the greenhouse
effect is that the the Earth some people
don't believe this but the basic
temperatures of the Earth are rising
that's why we're having all these storms
because they start I can go into the
Ecology of it but the bottom line is is
that we can reverse it and and who's
going to reverse it is you know if you
had gave me 10 pictures and said here's
the people that could change the whole
oil and gas business Willie Nelson
wouldn't be on the top he wouldn't be he
wouldn't be on the radar you know and
now now I'm working with Willie and and
I put him together with some people like
I call the head of Walmart who I'm doing
a lot of stuff with and I said hey look
you you know you guys need good press
right now and this would be the right
way to do good press when we put it
together and I put it together with some
of my other clients and and the truth is
the oil industry is not anti- anything
but no one's ever offered no one ever
spay spent the $38 million until he did
because he figured you know I got it
nobody can go after me I've already made
it in life and you know who'd think that
he'd attack it well you know so the good
news is is gr gas price goes up higher
which it's going to it's $5 a gallon in
the world the re everybody in America
says well gas went up not came down well
it CES down a few cents and they go ah
the hell it's going to $5 a gallon
because the Chinese have got 2% of
people driving which they now have as
many cars as we do in America India's
Got 2% of their their 1.4 billion people
driving that's as many cars we got and
they're paying $5 a GM if you got know
nothing about economics except supply
and demand and you know that that what's
going to happen is that the demand is
high so the supply is is finite so you
got to change it and what I'm saying is
Hey look let's change it and so we're at
the most exciting time in history so all
the people that that are are talented
are suddenly doing great stuff so the
big picture and I hope I am not I have
over anwered this question but you got
two things in the universe you got
entropy which is chaos and breakdown and
that's what media talks about by and
large the good news about success media
like you're doing now is it talks about
copy sin Sy YN not Sin Sin copy means
coming together at a new higher element
and that's what this show is doing and
that's what's happening with all the
media I went through the splash today
media and I just I was astounded at what
we can do and and the New Media of
Tomorrow is is the number one screen
we'll still watch this TV the number two
screen is going to be your cell phone
number three screen curiously
enough you know what a memory stick is
sure you know some called a thumb stick
it's about as big as your thumb and and
today you can buy a thumb stick with 20
gigs you can take the whole Library of
Congress and I remember when I got a 30
30 Meg hard drive this big paid $300 for
it and I was happy yeah but I just I
just bought a 4 gig for9 9 I thought God
what is this falling out of Heaven first
of all how do they hold all that and and
uh and then you know this morning's
paper showed that uh the biggest thing
at the electronic show is the new radio
that's going into every car has it so
you can put your memory stick in so it
has all your music I don't know what
that does to all the you know the stuff
with all the different automobiles like
General Motors has their own star system
and all et but now suddenly you're going
to take care of your music you're going
to carry your video and that that one
stick will carry it so the kids in the
backseat are watching you know stuff and
being entertained while you're on that
country long ride you know one of the
things I found fascinating about you
just talking to you is and I've
interviewed lots of speakers and and you
have speakers who are speakers and they
they they aren't necessarily business
people but one of the things I find Most
Fascinating about you is it seems to me
this my perception you're first and
foremost a business person who speaks
you you're very engaged in it you're
very learned in it you're you're
pursuing different information you've
actually are doing businesses in lots of
different areas nonprofit charitable
work but then also highly profitable uh
for-profit work um where does your
fascination for business and finance and
and all of that come where where's it
come curiously enough it's out of
spirituality Ian in other words Moses
was trained as a 33rd degree Mason and
he was a heck of a businessman down in
Ethiopia before he came back now the
opposite is true for Solomon Solomon
first of all he didn't wasn't ever
claimed wise until he put all these
business people together and he must
have been a master of good human
relations and what he did is he had all
the Phoenicians come and start doing
trading well once you start to trade
what are you going to trade well he has
this little lady down in Ethiopia called
the Queen of Sheba who's got
frankincense back then they didn't take
bass like remember I was a student
ambassador in India for a year and the
number one reason you marry a woman is
how does she smell because she's not
going to get a bath on a regular basis
you don't go to the Ganges River on a
regular basis so how does she smell well
frankincense was two or three things it
was a deodorant it was and all that and
all of a sudden you know you have S
as the world's greatest traitor which no
one ever talks about he was the richest
man the first trillionaire and all that
but he was the traitor of traitors
because he got all the ships together to
ship through all of Europe through all
the all the outline of Africa and all of
Asia he figured out how to do it but now
a suddenly he's getting all his
frankincense and and the story goes back
to Queen of Sheba now she's a young
woman right now I just went through the
whole Queen AA exhibit with with uh my
Minister and we I paid a private doset
to take me CU I I got so so many
questions that you know I believe that
you're alive at the level of your
curiosity you're alive at the level of
your imagination cuz my cliche is your
imagination creates a reality so the
bigger your imagination the better
reality you have and that's why I'm here
to be the gadfly the turn on people's
engine to great experience and great
awareness anyhow so Queen of Sheba now
is taking a trip like from LA to New
York but we're coming from Ethiopia as
frankincense on C on elephants which now
Solomon had never seen an elephant never
seen a lion because it just didn't exist
in Jerusalem right and she's coming with
an Entourage of 3,000 which remember
most towns back then were 30 or 50 we go
to this exhibit and we're looking at a
wall map as big as the wall we've got in
here and and I'm talking with a some you
know a rabbi is with us it's a solic
Solomon scholar and my Minister Dr trell
and we're going over this thing and
we're arguing policeman standing there
and he says you guys got it wrong now we
had it right the distance which is
equivalently America is going to take
her six months by lumbering elephant and
lumbering camels and uh but he said what
happened is you missed it she was in a
matr lineal a female run society and and
he had been in a patrol lineal a male
run male dominant our society is male
run basically now when you get to the
Hispanic part of America which is 48
million you got a female dominated
Society Mama runs the joint right but
suddenly you got this woman who's as
bright as he is and the first question
he answerers riddles to see if she's
smart and says how do you look through
sand and she said everyone knows that
glass and you go well you know so this
so what they did is test and and now he
already had 700 wives 300 concubines and
now he falls in love with this woman
obviously they create a baby and and a
lot of things are wrong and the Jewish
Family she's what's called a shika she's
a non-jew and and uh you know so
ultimately gets evicted and has to go
back and run her own kingdom and you
know lots of stuff but he still is
running the biggest empire in the world
and I said you got to run a big Empire
before you are considered wise so I said
I can do that and obviously I've got
seven Empires that I'm running that
making fortunes and then and answer your
question about uh I'm spokesperson for
two three major organizations right now
that uh you know Habitat for Humanity
which I totally believe in because I
think everybody should have a house and
I I we're trying to do that as an
entrepreneurial thing and otherwise um
spokesperson for the American Red Cross
where we need 38,000 pints of blood a
day and the people watching don't want
to give blood I don't like to give blood
but here's the deal if you don't give it
now when you need it it won't be there
and only 5% of us give it so at all my
mega events I always have a blood mobile
lineup to I've gotten three honorary
doctorates in Chiropractic one right
here in Dallas at U at Parker chiropract
college and and uh you know the guy runs
that is the genius of our time a lovely
guy who you ought to interview Dr Fab
manini's from Colombia his family is the
second richest in all of Latin America
and olive oil and weed and and um he
came was going to Harvard and then had
an accident Chiropractic solved it and
now he's running this whole school he's
a young kid he's built the biggest
seminar system we have 25,000 people in
Vegas in a couple days just it's amazing
what you know a young guy with good
mentorship can do and then um so what I
did with the chiropractors we got 62,000
doctors all to give blood they all
brought in 100 patients and adjust them
free one day and we had blood mobiles
everywhere and we went from dehydrated
to rehydrated which is what I'm teaching
is that entrepreneurship and charity are
pretty close and what it takes is one
idea times a right contact equals an
unlimited result M say that again say
that one idea one idea all you need is
the idea and then you borrow all the
resources so one idea plus the right
contact equals unlimited result the one
idea here is that we got the right media
the right then you got the right contact
where you get unlimited Result One idea
the idea for Chicken Soup for the Soul
times the right media exposure equals
110 million sales and then in 1998 I
read Steven Spielberg's book and it said
that he made 800 million on ET but a
billion and a half licensing so I said
hey Jack we're going on licensing he
saids what do you know I said nothing
but back to my system it's a system and
when I was in graduate school getting my
doctorate with Bucky Fuller you're
either in the system or you're out of
the system if you're out of the system
you can't figure out the system if you
decide to step into the system you say
look every system is finite it has a
beginning and end you can put a circle
around it and you master the system well
the system on licensing is $135 billion
in the US you know all the biggest names
and and so we decided to partner with
them and we partnered with Campbell
soups and I was I was on 400 million
Campbell Soup can where you know the
when you take the label off you open it
up and it had three chicken soup stories
and and we took that book to number one
and then I was on uh with Coca-Cola we
were with Diet Coke because people who
drink diet coke are better readers than
people who drink Coca-Cola so we're on
50 million Diet Coke cases a month for
six months and it sold two books uh our
book and nor Robert's book and all the
money it was our book was a couple Soul
nor Robert did hidden riches and she's a
bril she's the world's fastest writer
she writes in a yellow she writes a book
A Week under a couple different
pseudonyms like JD Rob sold 280 million
books I you know totally hand it to her
anyhow so but all that money went to the
charity Boys and Girls Clubs and we got
15,000 kids off the street and into Boys
and Girls Clubs because we got them
scholarships now you say well why can
you afford to do that well you the
reason you get rich is so you can afford
to do the stuff that nobody else can
afford to do you don't get rich at a at
a low level at an ego level you know you
get rich for yourself but once you
evolve in wisdom and evolve in awareness
and life is about awareness life is
about how much awareness you can
accumulate and that's why self-help is
so critical is it because if if if
awareness is a circle that you can make
30,000 you can't make any more until you
make it a bigger Circle 50,000 100,000
then it then what I teach now it's
easier to make a million than it is to
work on minimum wage but and a person on
minimum wage can make the million and I
I've taught a lot of people how to do
that if you stay contributing because
the minute you contribute back tithe
whether whether it's to a charity or a
church Temple City asham or mosque
suddenly then you know God pours in
infinite abundance hey there it's Chris
Weidner and I hope that you're enjoying
this interview that I did with one of
the legends of personal development and
if you'd like even more information and
great resources from the legends of
personal development all you have to do
is click on the link below in the
description and I've got a plenty more
for you so with that let's get back to
the interview people watching us and
they're going man I love this Mark vior
hands and read his books I'm stuck
here's where I am and wherever you are
it's great it's fine but they want to go
somewhere else they got to start where
they're at what do they do to to
increase that awareness what what did
where would they start what are the real
tangible effects if if you could say
here's what you do well the littlest
book I got out is Miracle of tithing and
if they call my office or write I'm
online everywhere but 800 sup book you
know they they'll give it to you for two
bucks it's a $10 book we just want them
everybody to have it but first story I
tell is exactly about my mentor who's
chip Collins when I'm bankrupt 31 years
AG going upside down and I say there's
got to be somebody young speaking at the
time everybody had gray hair they're a
senior they're a lawyer they're a doctor
or a celebrity like a Jane Fonda or
something and so I I had four roommates
I said somebody got to know somebody my
age doing it and they said oh there's
this one young kid who's a superstar at
Kodak and now he's teaching all of us in
real estate so name's chip Collins and I
heard it at 8:30 at 9:00 for the next
three hours I sit in this guy mesmerized
this office he he dances like on a head
of a pen he was so brilliant funny light
insightful I'm taking copious notes I
said chip let me take out to lunch and I
think he paid for lunch cuz I didn't
have any money I just went bankrupt the
day before I was so broke I had to check
a book out how to go bankrupt by
yourself you know and some lawyer was
hustling me I said man if I had $300 to
pay you I wouldn't be going bankrupt
right now anyhow it was my best worst
experience because if I didn't do that I
couldn't gotten out of hard Goods into
soft goods which is intellectual
property which is where I've made my
demand my my dominion and I Tred to
teach everybody to get in intellectual
property we'll talk about that next so
Chip the first story told me is that
that uh he heard a speaker of Kodak and
while he's taking notes on the left he
writes what he could do that he could do
this he could see himself through that
guy which is why it's important to have
a show like this because if they can see
themselves through you and I then they
can raise their station anyhow chip
comes out he's got a wife Don and two
kids all of whom are great friends of
course and um he's not making it
originally and and uh he's knocking on
doors in in the real estate offices and
he isn't getting any traction so he's
Catholic he goes into the Catholic
Church he's got 38 cents left and he
hasn't got enough money to feed his kids
can't buy milk for the babies nothing I
get goosebumps telling the story he goes
up to the Altar and says God here I've
lit the candle here's my 38 cents that's
all I got I got nothing else I'm a total
failure I'm going to have to go back to
Kodak nothing wrong with Kodak but I
want to be my own man I want to be an
entrepreneur and go from Little value to
a high value I want to sculpt my
personal value my company value my
future value and my life value as he's
walking out of the church the guy goes
excuse me aren't you chipcon guy say
goes you know he's shaken out of this
thing because he's been crying and he's
feeling said yeah he says you were in my
office the other day so many seminars
and I want to take him and here's a
check for
$400 wow chip kissed the guy and the guy
they had no idea that he was saving his
butt and Chip went and bought milk and
food for the kids that's a thousand
return right there from four 40 40 cents
to $400
yeah by the way I never thought about it
but you're you're correct I never I
didn't do the numerics but you're right
is it and chips and I talk about almost
every day on the phone because he's
still my conser I'm his so the first
thing is you got to have a dream the
next thing is you got to have a team you
know so they got to put together a team
and that if if if I see any withhold and
self- sabotages that most Americans
don't understand it one and one come
together if you look at it it is 11
right can you see 11 in that Christ
didn't do a miracle water in a wine at
can until he had 12 deciples Jack and
Mark are a team and and we stood back to
back and shoulder to- shoulder because
you're under attack I mean all those
people said no our wives said look
you're spending more time with Jack than
me why don't you marry Jack I go I don't
like Jack that way I mean not my
interest right and and you know Jack's
wife was asking him about it you know CU
our finances were going down and we knew
this thing would be the pen ultimate and
go up but we didn't you know we didn't
know how many fiery Hoops all we knew is
that we had to do it it was our there's
a there's a commission in your mission
and so you got to have a a you got to
have a big dream you got to have a great
team and then the third principle I
teach is you got to have multiple
streams you got to have a dream Martin
Luther King said I have a dream number
two you got to have a team King had a
team everybody that succeeds has a team
now guys like Thomas Edison had a team
Mr Barnes was a 5050 partner but totally
invisible yeah Edison was a front guy
Barnes was a back Barnes really did the
work Edison got all the credit and all
the media right behind Bill Gates you
got Steve bomber and you you and I
talked about bomber now bomber and I you
know met at a hotel and spent an hour
cuz they didn't have a room for bomber
which he was fried it was like midnight
and I got to last the hotel
yeah the same Hotel we're in right now
anyhow even the good hotel screws up you
know they immediately found a broom
closet or something to put them in I'm
sure anyhow but we had an hour together
so but bomber's invisible bomber can
walk anywhere but and Gates is the front
guy and bomber's doing and he also a
billionaire but is doing this great
strategic thinking and then you got to
have multiple streams of income the so
the number two problem is that most
people don't build together a team a
team means together everyone
accomplishes Miracles which is we've
also trademark because no one's ever
tried to do Miracles you can't do
Miracles as as a one-off you got to have
a team two or more gathered together
with a spirit of definite Harmony going
through one or more goals and our goal
was sell a million and a half and a year
and a half we did a million three and
then you our goal for 5 years was 50
million and now we've blown past 100
million and I said a billion no one's
done that including RK Rawlings you know
she's done about 500 million right now
so I want to go way way back and ask you
about earning that bicycle you you
talked about uh one of the lessons you
learned as a kid was you had to earn the
money for your own bicycle and uh tell
us some of your childhood cuz you know
we see you now and you're successful and
a speaker and you've obviously learned
so much but you didn't start out with
all this knowledge it's a process of
accumulating experiences and knowledge
and wisdom tell us some of those stories
from your your childhood when I was 9
years old my dad was a baker and my
parents are both Danish and we lived at
the Danish brother hood on Saturday
night I thought everybody was Danish I
mean you know you hung out with torval
and Yuna and Hans and names you don't
even know but um and ate food like Med
pills that you've never heard of and I
thought I thought hell everybody does
this and knows how to poke and stuff so
um we go to Denmark because my dad you
know knew that the two ways you learn a
space repetition which is why a show
like this is good because they keep
getting the same stuff over and over in
different ways and then number two is
that you get immersed in a culture and
and so I learned Danish as did my
brothers I've only got five brothers and
there's four of us left anyhow but I got
addicted to the lwh hand of our racing
bicycles this is 1957 so this is like
way before they came to the United
States something that you know I
desperately I had to have my heart of
hearts and I beat in my dad who is was a
free enterpriser but um you know he said
you can have it you're 21 I got him down
to 16 he said stop asking I said well
you teach free Enterprises more
enterprising you are dad the freeer you
are I said can I have it if I earn it
myself now in today's dollars I just
bought one of these kind of Bic that I
don't know if you're into big racing
bicycles but I own the thir Bri I bought
a $4,000 bike which the equivalent what
I bought back then which was $175 wow
right so Dad thinking like you got kids
you got nine-year-old at home right now
uh my youngest is 10 now yeah 10 could
your 10 year-old turn around $4,000 in 6
months by him or herself she probably
could but but but probably wouldn't
probably wouldn't yeah well Dad was
convinced I wouldn't so this was a
no-brainer and I'm reading I'm a Boy
Scout and I'm in route to being an eagle
and all that but I I you know raise a
lot of money for the Boy Scouts too cuz
I love them and I created a whole new
thing to raise them 5 million last year
anyhow but I'm reading Boy Scout Life
Magazine it says you can sell greeting
cards on consignment I said what a cool
idea I looked up the word in the
dictionary and it said you don't have to
pay for it you just sell it then you
idea that's a better
idea cost me zip I can afford this
consignment stuff I don't know how it
works but I got me some of it so I go
out and uh my mother said just smile at
everybody cuz she was a great saleswoman
she ran to front of the bakery for my
daddy and um I always offer Al I didn't
know alternative Choice like today I'd
teach you in a sales seminar but and
remember I'm selling to women which is
my market then my market today 87% of
all books are sold to women that's why
you guys got to make sure you're selling
you and and Mr Roland are only selling
to women anyhow so the snow is deep back
in Wan Illinois and I got a big free
mint and I i' ring doorbell they come to
the door and I go like this and they'd
say young man come in here blow the nose
which you know and once you're
physically face to face you got a
prospect that suddenly became a suspect
looks like she's going to become a
customer and and if I knew then what I
know now would become a C client and a
raving fan and and how old were you nine
nine I didn't know all this then but it
works so well I said I'm earning my own
bicycle by merchandising these Christmas
cards would you like to invest I knew
the word then invest because Dad said
you ask them to do invest so I said
invest in one or two and most of them
took two and they were you know a dollar
each and I got 50% of it so you know I
sold I had to sell over 700 almost 800
bux of Christmas cards to have the money
to buy it and then next spring I bought
a bike and then every year after that I
bought a new bicycle and it got me going
cuz I started in my own little
neighborhood where we knew everybody
there was only Jews and danish people
living there and you know then I I said
God this is working so well if Christmas
doesn't come too fast I can make a lot
of money because almost everybody bought
and especially like on Saturday and
Sunday afternoons it just I
went and it just it it was just clicking
and then my dad did the financial whamm
he says you want to go to college I said
I think so I don't know now he' never
gone to colge College he only had
limited education was technically
illiterate as was my mom you know if you
don't read past third grade in your
first language in literate you're
illiterate in your second language and
I'm picking on them I just you know and
they wanted us to go to college but they
want they he said get clear you're going
to get to pay for this so he took half
my money and put it in now he didn't
know then that that was going to pay for
me to become a rock star because when
the Beatles came out 1962 I call my best
little scanda huie and Buddy and I said
Gary we're starting a rock group he said
what do you play I said nothing I said
what do you play nothing I said we're
qualified because we just saw I don't
know if you saw the Ed Sullivan Show
when the Beatles came out and went from
Zero to Hero well I didn't see it in
real time but you saw it I've seen it
rerun reran whatever the right grammar
is that is anyhow um well I saw it in
real time and within two weeks we're
making $17 an hour as a musician but
back to I didn't know that I was going
to be one of my many missions is to
teach everybody why they got to
contribute and how much benefaction you
get and how it 100 folds which I can
teach 100 folding here in a second if
you want um but the amazing thing was
that we start this band and then YMCAs
are basically dark they play basketball
for a little while on Friday and
Saturday night and then they're black
they're empty yeah so I went to the head
of the YMCA as a kid and I said hey look
uh you got nothing happening here how
would you like 50% of something rather
than nothing he said well what are you
going to do and I said well um I'll take
out a full page ad which cost like 50
bucks which was big stuff if you're 16
years old and it said The Messengers my
group is coming and we'll play and and
we'll charge $5 a person I have my older
brothers being taking all the money and
they said don't we deserve part of this
I said no you you asked for a salary and
you get a salary if you asked to
participate and want to invest then you
get to you know so I I started 16 years
old knowing that and like we'd have a
thousand people well that's five grand
and I got 2,500 some nightes we'd have
2,000 people showing up so I'd walk away
with five grand you got five grand at a
16year old you are in giant giant money
and I wasted all of it because I didn't
have the awareness that I teach today I
write all the money books like cracking
the millionaire coding one millionaire
and you know how to achieve F prosperity
cuz I teach how to you know I I teach
it's a Trilogy you got to learn it then
you got to earn it then you got to
return it you don't get to
keep you know and everything you're
talking about I see just a streak of
salesmen and some people don't like that
term salesman I'm not a Salesman but
isn't sales fundamental to life I I
think it's the key thing you guys wrote
it into your book 12 pillars it's the
key skill that everybody's got to have
because one of the lines you had is that
all life is sales and sales is a a
Danish word in case you didn't know it
and it means to serve and and then what
you say well what does a master teacher
say well the greatest amongst you is
servant of all so if if you if you don't
learn the skill then of sell then you
can't sell now a teacher sells the
students un learning a lawyer sells the
judge in the court and and decline on
paying ultimately you know or whoever's
got to pay a doctor sells the patient
and it's sort of a subservient role that
I'm the doctor and and like right now
I'm having a little problem with my
cervical six and I go into the doctor
and he gave me two Alternatives he says
we can either medicate you for the rest
of your life to get you out of pain or I
can you know make you 2 Ines shorter and
I said that one ain't going to work I
said I said I love alop theic MD
medicine but I believe there are 28
forms of medicine so you know I got 27
other modalities that I'm testing right
now and I've I've gone to seven
different healers to regen I had my
spine regenerated once before when
somebody offered to cut out a ruptured
disc and I rebuilt it so you know I'm
going to all these healers all over the
country cuz they exist we're in we're in
the greatest time ever and and
alternative medicine is bigger than than
standardized medicine in America today
whether it's homeopathic or herbal or
Chiropractic or NDS or whatever right
and you know we have a hospital where I
I have own a second home in Kona Hawaii
and uh the guy who created the pacemaker
is a dear friend of mine Dr Earl bachan
and he just put up $100 million for a
hospital that offers all 28 modalities
well when I leave and fly back tomorrow
to Hawaii you know I'm going through
there to find out there's got to be one
modality that can regenerate this
without surgery I I am very pro surgery
if you need it but if you can avoid it
uh you know let's avoid it I we get the
best medical doctors in the world but
they know three things and I want to
know somebody that knows a 100 things
does that make sense yeah yeah totally
in other words let's go back to my dad a
second with that story is that when my
dad came from Denmark during the height
of the depression he thought America had
hope written on it and it did for him
hope at the front end increases your
options so if you got one option that's
not enough options remember I said they
got to have multiple options so the
third Point I've been teaching multiple
streams of income because you got one
stream of income and that stream gets
shut off for whatever reason you can
just turn up the volume and the other
streams like I got 28 major streams of
income and I just I keep turning them up
and then I put I teach you put an
impressario you put a champion you put a
a COO a chief operating officer in front
of each one just like Bill Gates does or
you know and then you know just turn up
the volume and then you go on and do the
rest of the stuff cuz if you have a team
and you need four kinds of people I'm a
creative I create brand new stuff then
you have you have an advancer which
turns out my partner Jack is an advancer
my wife is an advancer uh Bob Allen's an
advancer art link letter turns out to be
both a creative who's an advancer I just
finished a book called how to make the
rest of your life the best of your life
with him then you need a refiner which
is your legal mind or engineering mind
or medical mind then last but not least
in my business you need an Executor
publisher that sells it or a a seminar
seat filler that fills the seminar or
you need a TV Outreach like this so
sense yeah it does it makes sense how
how then a person again you're you're
you've created such an Empire uh that
plal Empires yeah but the whole thing
wrapped up is your Empire the whole
story of the parable of the talents is
that when Jesus is leaving he says the
Master is leaving he said here's your
talents and two guys multiplied him
doubled them one guy buried him but the
first line he says you have several
abilities meaning you got several
talents you got ability to make multiple
sources no one's supposed to have one
source of income that's a job so there
there's a man or a woman who's sitting
here watching and they're mid-level
manager at a corporation they're making
$35,000 a year and they're saying I've
got a big dream in my heart where do I
start I want to have an Empire they know
you knew I'm sure before before chicken
soup went big time that that the empire
was inside of you right that it was
there it was a sense of Destiny Acorn
ready to become an over right yeah a
sense of of Destiny there's people that
are watching right now but they don't
see the real of it but they know it's
there what do they do so do your main
job your mid-level management job better
than you've ever done it in that one
Circle but now you start your MSI just
like Jack and I did chicken soup
part-time until we could do it full-time
and then chicken soup got so big that
our main business which was speaking
became small by comparison financially
and people said why do you do it I mean
some of our mutual friends have said why
don't you just quit and retire because
there's no payoff in that right your
life it is creative I mean you know in
the first line in the Bible says in the
beginning God created well if you and I
are made the image and likeness of God
then your job is to create and if I
really am creating I'm going to touch
all seven billion people around the
planet in a multitudinous a lot of
different ways source and serve them and
and be become even more massively
charitable I mean one of the things I
wrote down because I saw one of my peers
write it down in Horatio that you know
you want to give a billion dollars away
in your life I'd like to do that and I'm
busy creating it yeah and it's fun to
create I mean being on the show there's
no mandate that I got to be in your show
but I'm glad to do it and we're creating
some new stuff here and hopefully they
catch the contagion of that they get the
contact high from us to go out and do it
cuz I've gotten a contact high from a
lot of people I've had 44 great mentors
yeah I want to talk to you about some of
those mentors and people that have
influenced and shaped your life let's
talk uh about mentors and let's talk
about books um what are the books and
the people that have shaped your life
you know Charlie Jones always says in
five years you'll be the books you read
and the people you you meet what it
tapes you listen to and the tapes you
listen to right the the the input you're
bringing in right so what have been the
books and tapes that have really
profoundly impacted your life
particularly before you had all of this
what were the ones that you listened to
that created that or helped you create
and then who are the people that have
really profoundly influenced your life
three questions okay so number one is
the books I'd say everybody's got to
read think Grow Rich and you got to read
it a multitude of times like I probably
read it 200 times and You' take
ownership because it's a book that says
there's a secret on every page but it's
a secret of the spirit and turns out
that I am part of a Major Video coming
out called the secret and it it is
really a wonderful documentary made by
an Australian lady Ronda burn and um I I
am honored that I'm on it I'm featured
with some of the greatest minds of our
time Steve cvia is on it I mean I could
go through the list of the who's who
it's literally The Who's Who of the
worlds I got Nelson mandala they got a
lot of very very famous people and I'm
I'm glad that I got into that August
here so thing gr Rich had a profound
effect on me uh I had um a lot of books
that you won't know like Resurrection by
Neville you know which says you know you
got to go into the secret place of the
most high and you got to close your eyes
before you go to sleep and you got to be
doing the right breathing and that and
and then you get a a fixity of thought
and we had fixity of thought of seeing
ourselves as number one New York Times
number one Publishers Weekly number one
USA Today and we're the only book ever
that's been all three and you get that
picture and and you know Jack and I
locked in on that kind of picture
because of Neville's book he says your
mind thinks in pictures so you got to
put it in a holding pattern Bill Gates
saw in his mind's eye and he says it
that I see a computer in every house
well I see one of my books in every
house I see one of my tapes in every
house and right now you know we're we're
taking the market down to the lowest
price level and you're going to even
help me get distributed at Costco price
club we talked about last night which is
so wonderful I just can't even believe
it so so there's you know what we want
to do is I want to make education
available palpable you know and anybody
watching if they go to my website mark
victor.com
the most listened to tape of all times
which affected me greatly was Earl nals
do you know the title of it The
Strangest Secret Strangest Secret now
Earl had a hundred million listeners and
I was with him last week before he died
we toured Australia together and uh did
you listen to it on the SE on the yeah
the old days I I actually just listened
to it on a CD but it sounded like it was
on an old LP which they had this crackly
sound we got rid of all that yeah that
was done 50 years ago what what happened
is Vic Conan who went to Harvard with my
partner Dr Campfield you know uh called
me up and he said look uh we did a test
of all of our 300,000 uh subscribers
they want your voice on with Earls and
they want you to bring this up to date
50 well I I I asked Vic I said look we
want to give this to the planet this is
this is a planetary resource and it's
the front end so people get listening
because I want everyone to get hooked on
this so if you go to my website you can
just download it free you put it in your
iPod you listen to it strange stranger
secret there's Earl and then there's me
in an echo chamber explaining how that
applies 50 years later and it you know I
did an hour and ear did an hour so it's
two hours solidated one you really need
it on your iPod or your PDA or your
computer or your laptop and Mark Victor
hanson.com yeah Mark Victor hanson.com
and and then the other thing I want you
to watch is I'm defending our industry
we have a an adversary who had a number
one book called sham how the self-help
industry is making America helpless so
couple weeks ago um Anderson Cooper live
who's the next Larry King they're making
him Larry as big as Larry and and he
calls up his office calls up and said
it's 2 afternoon and said can you be
here to film at 8:30 to debate this guy
I said that's I got a lot of other plans
but I will switch all of them because
this is a critical that somebody defends
this industry sure I am successful
because it's I'm successful because of
books like th and Grow Rich successful
because of tapes like stranger SEC and
the thing that I'd be honored to bring
it up to date 50 years after Earl made
so many people so wealthy with it and so
because he did it for his own insurance
company did you know that no he did it
for his own insurance company the
insurance company when he was away on
vacation for two weeks just skyrocketed
and they had it to the wife and the kids
save marriages I get goosebumps cuz it
did so much good the publisher um of his
stuff was a guy named Lloyd conet right
that's how the company became uh night
Andale conet and now Vic conut is the
son of Carson behind that Carson is is
the young 20 something you know who's
the brilliant and uh he just a young kid
that understands how to computerize all
this stuff and you
know there I want to pay them a great
compliment here if I could real quick
when we were doing our first book tour
my own publisher didn't celebrate us and
you know we' rock through we went to
number one the first day with Amazon and
all that and sold more books and any
over and we melted down Amazon because
we did three million emails and said if
you do this we give you $250 worth of
stuff called an ethical bribe and we
went wow and it started at 87,000 by
10:00 it was 705 we melt down by 3:00
when I figured out out put it back on
we're number one and number one
continuously for a long time with the
one minute millionaire we go to n Con in
Chicago and we're burned I mean we've
been doing media at 6:00 in the morning
which means you got about 4: and then
you know media media Med now it's 4:00
and we got to go do our taping at n con
for this
series we arrive there and we're just
you know coats over our shoulder ties
down and we're don't know if we're going
to have enough energy to do it and Vic
Kut comes out with 168 employees with
balloons and our our corporate symbol as
as you know is is a butterfly cuz it's
the universal symbol of spiritual
illumination and we just we are so wound
tight I mean they're all cheering us
giving us sustaining Ovation saying you
know playing Rocky in the back and going
wow this is like way cool so so I I am
addicted to helping out Vic Kona do
anything and he he really wants everyone
to because two-thirds of us are auditory
Learners we don't learn very well uh
just reading a book so you need to in so
let's if two-thirds of us are auditory
let's give away some of the stuff
auditorally so they get it and I don't
care where they listen to it on their if
they still have a cassette they or or a
CD or their iPod or whatever new vehicle
they got or today uh because of the
memory stick put it on your memory stick
but it's free just go to the website and
get it what people really influenced
your life as a young man what mentors
took you under their wing and and taught
you and you learned from who invested in
you well first of all I'm in graduate
school and I'm you know I almost failed
out of school because I was Mr party 101
man I just I was good at party and and
somehow I could find them and then when
they offered to let me leave school I
said whoa I I like this place I want to
go a decade I want to be a university
Professor which I was at Colorado for a
while and you know now I'm buying a
university so um with some other guys
anyhow I decided to get good and I
started getting A's and and uh I'm in
graduate school and like graay Anatomy
to physiology is Alfred Richardson Dr
Richards and I become great friends and
I'm in Al's office and and uh I was
getting A's in his class and just I I
just I love the whole body and how it
worked and he made it so real and
applicable and he was an Assa advisor
and and he said it's students first
faculty second Administration never and
I just I loved his model and he said one
day I'm in there talking to Dr
Richardson he said hey Mark the smartest
guy in this planet because our school
Southern University hired everybody at
Harvard Wharton Yale and Stanford that
got fired automatically at 65 30 years
ago we were totally into an agism right
and now suddenly they're there and he
said you got to hear this guy Dr
Buckminster Fuller and there 5,000
students in the arena we're sitting in
the front row because of who he is and I
just I watched Bucky I saw his Aura just
emanate out like six feet in pink and
white and you know yellow as the color
of intelligence I
went I thought I knew everything right
I'm in graduate school and I'm about to
finish my doctorate and I just I thought
I was somebody and then all a sudden I
heard somebody that was really brilliant
in 15 different channels had 2,000 major
inventions had written 40 books finished
Einstein unified field Theory explained
on the schedule E equals MC squ e is all
the energy of physical Universe m is
conal doesn't matter whether it's this
or this or anything hard it's tied up
and then and then the rest c squared C
Bucky had to do math new mathematics
called triangled instead of squared it's
to the triangled anyhow you know it's
radiant and I went wow that's the guy I
got to hang with I went to his office I
got a job I was a seventh one of his
students that travel literally around
the world you know I was getting paid
$200 a month as a a research assistant
for seven years and I just I don't I
think I own Bucky's body of material but
B Bucky W to figure out how to make the
world work for 100% of humanity he'd
been in the Navy during World War I
that's how old he was right I came in he
was 71 and I was 21 and um he wowed my
soul and and just said hey look
somebody's got to take care of the
ecosphere the little biosphere that's
wrapped around this planet that's only
10 miles high and 10 miles deep you
can't live except in that and we're
polluting it we're killing ourselves in
the old days if you thought the Earth
was flat you could pollute in Kansas
City which they did and they moved at 20
mi cuz there so much horse PTI the
horses couldn't lift their feet did you
know that so they just moved all of
Kansas City learning all sorts of things
from you Mark well I know all sorts of
stuff I I got to use CNN term I got a
lot of factoids in there you know so
Bucky just wob my soul made me bigger
and then I tried to be Bucky which was
dysfunctional which is I was building
geodesic domes at a rate of $2 million a
year and I built the Wall Street Racket
Club and botanic aviaries and arboretums
all kinds of cool stuff but I you know
when the oil embargo hit I was building
out a PVC for polyvinyl chloride I
petrochemicals and I was doing $40,000 a
month and I thought I was big stuff
right with monsano and I
went Bob Allen said how do you sleep
when you went bankr I said I slept like
a baby he says what do you mean I said I
slept two hours and I
cried anyhow um then I had a tape fall
out because I'd sold so well going
through college that somebody gave me an
audio tape by cavat Robert the dean of
speakers I wrote him a letter and said I
want to Apprentice to you and he he
wrote me back and it was just amazing
and then I went to hear him speak I I
had two guys put up credit cards cuz I
had no money to go to a seminar that's
how critical C is cuz a lot of people
don't know yeah Cav Robert is a dean of
speakers he was a lawyer he was he was
trained by um Will Rogers and everybody
else founder of NSA founder of the
national speaker Association but never
started until he was 65 and and was
solid until he was 89 and heward our
like the Tony Emy and Oscar in our
industry is the cavat right yeah and uh
I just went Kavin said you could do a
multi-authored book I'm young and
impressionable I hit the guy next to me
I said are you any an editor cuz I'm a
great writer he said yeah I was head of
law school Journal Keith the green we
did our first book that year I made
$200,000 selling a book from a platform
called Stand Up speak out and win and
since then I've never stopped doing
multi-author books I got a lot solo but
I got I've written 117 books now in the
last two decades so we've done a lot of
books huh what are you most excited
about right
now making Humanity work just because
there's so many people from all over I
mean not only America but like one of my
best students is Jose espia second
poorest country is Guatemala comes up
flies up monthly spend some time in one
of my seminars in the first six months
of this year 32 years old he made a
million1 100,000 and Guatemala got hit
by Wilma and uh lost 100,000 houses he
said hey look um we could do a web
ucation seminar where you stay at home
and just have a little camera on you and
and do your seminar and uh we raised
enough money to build 10,000 houses I
got Brian Tracy I got Bob Allen I got
Jack Canfield I got de we all did it in
one day we stayed at home and we filled
every movie theater in gu City I mean
that could not have happened before
right now mhm amazing you are an amazing
guy and uh so much knowledge and wisdom
that we didn't even get to and truly a
Renaissance Man I mean just listening to
you so much uh uh and and a person who
has achieved a lot for himself but a
person who wants to give and is generous
uh with time and your energy and your
your material possessions and I
appreciate you being here good to get to
know you little bit thanks thanks Chris
to see Chris's interview with Jim ran
which was the last time Jim ran did a
video interview check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there what you're about to watch is the
last video interview that Jim ran ever
did he sits down with Chris Weidner to
talk about how to get the right mentors
set meaningful goals and stop being
broke